everything that irritates us about
others
can lead us to an understanding of
ourselves
the greatest tragedy of the family
is the unlived lives of the parents
i am not what happened to me
i am what i chose to become
loneliness does not come from having no
people about one
but from being unable to communicate the
things that seem important to oneself
or from holding certain views
which others find inadmissible
life really does begin at 40.
up until then
you are just doing research
every form of addiction is bad
no matter whether the narcotic be
alcohol morphine
or idealism
people will do anything no matter how
absurd to avoid facing their own souls
thinking is
difficult that's why most people judge
shame is a soul-eating emotion
you are what you do
not what you say you'll do
the healthy man does not torture others
generally it is the tortured who turn
into torturers
midlife is the time to let go of an
over-dominant ego
and to contemplate the deeper
significance of human existence
we are born
at a given moment
in a given place
and like vintage years of wine
we have the qualities of the year
and of the season in which we are born
[Music]
when an inner situation is not made
conscious
it appears outside as fate
children are educated by what the
grown-up is
and not by his talk
man cannot stand a meaningless life
where your fear is
there is your task
man needs difficulties
they are necessary for health
don't hold on to someone who's leaving
otherwise you won't meet the one who's
coming the least of things with the
meaning is worth more in life than the
greatest of things without it
what did you do as a child that made the
hours past like minutes
herein lies the key to your earthly
pursuits
[Music]
the greatest and most important problems
of life are all fundamentally insoluble
they can never be solved but only
outgrown
knowing your own darkness is the best
method for dealing with the darkness of
other people
depression is like a woman in black
if she turns up
don't shoo her away invite her in
offer her a seat
treat her like a guest
and listen to what she wants to say
knowledge rests not upon truth alone
but upon error also
every human life contains a potential
if that potential is not fulfilled
then that life was wasted
the meeting of two personalities is like
the contact of two chemical substances
if there is any reaction
both are transformed
if a man knows more than others
he becomes lonely
as any change must begin somewhere
it is the single individual who will
undergo it and carry it through
the change must begin with one
individual
it might be any one of us
nobody can afford to look around and to
wait for somebody else to do
what he is loathed to do himself
one day you will regret that you did not
hear these quotes earlier do not lose
the opportunity watch our next video